the Trump presidency has been many
things many terrible things as our
president likes to say but one of the
things that it's been is what I call a
swamp job Trump ran on draining the
swamp right getting the influence of
lobbyists out of government and he
claimed that he was going to do it he
can't claim he was going to get rid of
not only the lobbyists but the crony
political deals he was going to get rid
of all that bad stuff he's actually done
the opposite right he's filled the swamp
more than any president in recent
history and The Daily Beast did a very
interesting examination it looked at the
341 Trump nominations only for positions
that have to be confirmed by the Senate
right those are the those are the that's
the universe of nominations and
appointments that The Daily Beast looked
at and what The Daily Beast found is
that 179 out of 341 Trump nominations
more than half had conflicts of interest
of some kind 31 percent of the
nominations actually nominees I guess I
would call them worked in the industry
that they were supposed to be regulating
and 20 percent lobbied for or were
lawyers for or represented industry
members of the industry they were being
nominated to regulate 11 of the 341
actually received payments or campaign
donations from members of the industry
that they were supposed to be regulating
this is a phenomenon called regulatory
capture okay regulatory capture is a
it's a political concept it is a
political concept and regulatory capture
defined is a form of government failure
that occurs when a regulatory agency
created to act in the public interest
instead advances the commercial or
political concerns of special interest
groups that dominate the industry or
sector it is charged with regulating now
you might be hearing me say this and you
might be thinking and I know that some
of you right-wingers will say this
you'll say wait David
of course the people that are being
nominated to regulate these industries
are from those industries you become an
expert in an industry by working in
if you're going to regulate that
industry or members of that industry it
makes sense you need people with
knowledge of the industry we should want
this the problem with that argument is
that Donald Trump himself made a huge
deal out of stopping what he described
right as the revolving door of people
going back and forth from working in
private industry lobbying for that
industry regulating that industry as
part of an administration back to
lobbying or working in the industry
directly Trump himself said that he
wasn't going to be hiring the lobbyists
and the corporate insiders and these
types of people so if your argument is
oh this is no big deal because everybody
does it then did you believe that Trump
was lying when he promised not to do
this exact thing but there's a further
issue here right which is there's a
difference between being knowledgeable
in the industry you're going to be
regulating right we could say well you
could look to academics right academics
would be very knowledgeable in many of
these industries right there's they're
not all academic disciplines but many of
them are but the academics would be far
less likely to have the conflicts of
interest what what we are really
pointing out is a problem here and what
the article from The Daily Beast is
pointing out is the issue is that there
are financial conflicts of interest here
more than half of them have those
absolutely horrifying
and again if you aren't worried about
this did you not care about it when
Trump said he would drain the swamp or
did you assume that he was lying to you
and you don't care that he's a liar I'm
curious to hear from Trumpets what you
think about this you can also discuss
this not just with me but with other
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
on our reddit discussion forum ok david
pakman.com slash read it I am there Pat
is there and almost 5,000 of our viewers
and listeners are there so check it out
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the
free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS